isabelle morini-bosc vous est ce que
c'est vrai a dit là et dès que vous avez
rencontré dsk et qui il a succombé à
votre charme
il n'a pas succombé à son charme mais ce
qui me lutine tout ce qui me tenaient
tout ce qui passait j'étais attiré par
tous y compris les boutons porte qui
s'agitent et un peu
[Applaudissements]
alors à quand et comment s'est passée à
côté vous ça a été j'ai été extrêmement
en furtif c'est à dire qu'il y aura une
soirée il était placé à côté de moi et
qu'il était ainsi fait que comme le
serpent qui se mord la queue elle
pouvait pas ne pas palper touchés et et
romont de bois calmez-vous silverlight
était obligé mais effectivement de faire
ça pour pour pour vous retirez c'est
alors et vous à mai mais bon ça c'est
rien mais ils vous aiment vraiment
proposer quelque chose moi il m'a pas
dit tu veux chambre temps ah oui oui
mais il l'a proposé dix fois à d autres
jeunes femmes dans la même soirée
j'ai vu face à une maquilleuse de france
3 où il a laissé semble en avoir oublié
son fils au fax dans la loge c'était
l'époque la grande mode vous filofax
alors pour les jeunes qui vous regardent
le filofax émergents
ouais c'est un agenda voilà il occupe
ici là il a appelé le lendemain en
disant je veux récupérer j'ai besoin me
joindre cette jeune femme qui a sûrement
dû me mettre mon agenda de côté ils
avaient vu venir tout ça sans lui à ce
france 3 il veut mais on va vous le
retrouvez votre agenda monsieur strauss
kahn non je veux je veux pas moi je suis
un socialiste je veux embêter personne
je vais m'en occuper moi même et puis
finalement quand il a compris que l'on
sent il aurait pas gain de cause il a
raccroché mais fut rima et c'était moi
je les ai vus à airtel fait la malle on
retrouve est toujours là